absolutely and actually I'm going to
give it to you Yasser because you guys
are very good bodies and I want you to
get all your questions in I don't want
you to miss any one of them so
hit Eugene with something first of all
Eugenio Welcome to our studio so nice to
have you here how are you liking Saint
Louis
yeah I'm very happy to be here this is
my first time and I'm glad I made it
here because it's incredible City you
know and it very much deserves the the
name that it is the
how do you call this the chest city of
the world yeah nice well the Chastity of
the world likes to invite uh you a chess
Legend to the city I've been singing
your praises and telling the people of a
time we shared in Hyde Park in London
where you sang For Me Frank Sinatra's My
Way
and you absolutely stunned me uh your
your great singer Eugene as well as a
great chess player
well I I tried to be but uh usually I
use my singing so that when I exercise
usually I exercise one hour in the
morning and one hour in the half late in
the afternoon by walking uh it helps me
uh
uh not minding the time walking when I'm
you know uh
singing music Sometimes some people
thought that I was kind of crazy because
but they didn't know that I was just
singing to you know to uh to pass a time
yes you need Yasser to be walking next
to you I appreciated it very much and
again uh wonderful to have you in studio
Anastasia and Christian would like to
ask you also questions about your career
and uh Anastasia yeah you you played so
many chess Olympics if we are not
mistaken it's 22 Olympics I mean what a
record uh maybe you can remember which
Olympiad was the very special for you
which one of them you remember the most
well I think those games I played
especially against the grand Masters in
1974 when I got my Grandmaster title in
nice Olympiad and of course
those games when we made our best finish
in
in outside of the 74 Olympia that was in
1988
in Thessaloniki Greece wherein we I
think we placed seventh overall so that
was a great achievement for the
Philippines and then of course the one
the last Olympiad I played in 2016
because
I made I was surprised myself of my
performance and
and I think I got the bronze medal on
the third board scoring nine wins you
know and two draws so uh I was surprised
myself that's why after that I did not
play anymore in in future Olympia
because I don't think I can duplicate
Eugene in your uh induction uh Speech
you mentioned Wesley so and your
relationship with him as well and he
always uh talks highly of you tell us a
bit about your relationship with one of
the United States best players right now
Wesley so yeah we have very good
relationship with uh with with Wesley
because
I was very much impressed with him you
know when he was still young and uh I in
some of my or in one of my interviews I
said that Wesley is a rare find you know
and we have to give all the support he
needed and I was not wrong because I saw
that he could promote or develop his
chess skill on his own without uh
seconds I noticed that that on his own
he is able to improve his chest
knowledge somehow
typical of Bobby Fisher was that the
biggest Factor when you try to assess
his potential the fact that he was so
well versed in working on his own and
coming up with ideas on his own yeah
let's uh
that's part of the consideration you
know at a young age I seldom see young
players able to improve by themselves
normally you have somebody to assist you
so that means that on his own by
studying alone he can improve himself
and the thing is he like very much to
study chess you know he loved chess very
much so very important and you also
supported his move from the Philippines
to the United States you felt like this
would open a lot of doors for him do you
feel the same way right now yes yes of
course
it's important that what your heart or
your mind a wish for you to do then you
do it you know anyway among Filipinos uh
we we consider still uh
Wesley as our Countryman as a Filipino
just the same and uh
we wish him although he is representing
the United States that's good because he
is being well supported also here in the
U.S so as much as Americans would wish
him success
same same also with us Filipinos Eugene
thank you very much for joining the show
and congratulations once again on your
career and your induction
congratulations thank you very much for
inviting me here lovely to see you again
thank you very much in the meanwhile we
do have a